lester schum is a district councillor
now facing the prospect of life in
prison after being charged
with violating hong kong's tough new
national security law
if he's convicted his political career
like his freedom will be over
on sunday he was one of 47 activists
told to appear at police stations
across the territory with his wife of
four weeks by his side
shum insisted the fight for democracy in
hong kong
must go on i want to tell all of
the hong kong people no matter where you
are to keep
faithful and to be hopeful and to
continue our struggle
lester do you believe you'll be
disqualified no i'm not coming
i had asked shum that same question
seven months ago
after he was detained for taking part in
a small protest
in breach of social distancing rules i
really don't know
whether i would be disqualified or not
but i can say for sure that
there is a chance for being happy shum
was a candidate in an
unofficial poll held last july to
pre-select candidates
for legislative elections due two months
later
elections which were later cancelled
with the government citing covert 19.
the strategy of the pro-democracy camp
had been this
gain a simple majority in parliament
block important legislation
and forced the resignation of the
territories leader carrie lamb
but such tactics common in democracies
around the world
are enough to get you arrested in
today's hong kong
and in january the police came knocking
rounding up 55
activists including u.s human rights
lawyer john clancy
who was not charged on sunday but joshua
wong
the territory's best known pro-democracy
voice was
he's already in jail after being
convicted of organizing
an unauthorized protest two years ago
when the beijing-imposed national
security law took effect here
kari lam said it would only affect a
small number of people
so far it's led to almost a hundred
arrests
with half that number now charged human
rights groups say that hong kong is
heading in an authoritarian direction
with new laws and regulations curbing
freedoms
once promised by china gradually the
voices of descent
are being silenced adrian brown al
jazeera
hong kong